the
righteous predecessors in their dealings with people in their interpersonal relations and we said that bringing
ourselves closer to their biographies is the remedy for so many uh dimensions of Our Lives
it is the antidote to so many uh unethical practices or even personality traits uh that
seep in due to the other lives that we interact with the lives of those who
are not as privileged to be refined by the Revelation the way they sell it for
the way the early Muslims were the prophet salallahu alaihi wasallam said the very best people
as my generation than those who follow them and so those first three generations are extra
special and we're not confining ourselves to the first three but it's an indication of the
earliest periods of the
ummah
that we want to pay extra attention to to recalibrate so we begin now we're going
to try to cover three or four or five sections per week and I'm gonna try
to give them a overarching theme if I can because the sections are rather short they're
rather brief and so this one will mostly be about humility but in practice you know
like humility is not a Feeling or not just the feeling and that's important you know
even from the great wisdom of the Prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam when he said in the
Hadith
nobody enters Jannah Paradise if there's a Spec's weight of Pride or arrogance in their heart
they said ya rasulullah we like to have nice clothes nice shoes are we arrogant they
got worried and then he said no Allah is beautiful he loves Beauty
arrogance is the rejection of Truth this is a practice a conduct right so humility is
also a conduct and it is it is the belittlement of people and some Scholars pointed
out that look at the two examples he gave he said rejection of truth that's an
outward thing that you do belittling people is an inward state of yours you look at
people like their nobodies like their cockroaches right who are you and the wisdom and the
beauty in giving those two definitions One external indicator of arrogance One internal indicator of arrogance
is so that you check both inside and out for because a Spec's weight will destroy
you because someone may pretend outwardly may act in practice humble like they have humility but
inside they're arrogant and if someone gives you some advice and you say great point but
in your heart you're saying who does this person think they are to give me nasiha
you got to check both sides inside and outside and likewise some person can think that
they're humble because they have this like warm and cuddly feeling inside but when it comes
to the people they are defiant when it comes to the truth that people bring them
and so humility at large inwardly and outwardly is what some of these chapters will be
uh covering through anecdotes from the lives of the salaf so the first section he says
here he starts the whole book with this section Allah
they do not hope for the approval of the people instead and instead of that they
prefer seeking the pleasure of Allah and of course that needs a little bit of a
qualifier because everyone can read that line on their personality type I don't need to please
nobody I don't care what they think about me I just care about Allah no you're
actually wrong because if you cared about Allah there were a lot of times when Allah
wanted you to be gentle and sort of be flexible and wanted you to be agreeable
and wanted you to be polite and right and the opposite is also true some people
sort of like say Islam is about being kind and gentle and merciful and compassionate even
at the expense of compromising our relationship with Allah that that also is very wrong and
so what he is saying is their ultimate objective is pleasing Allah and getting his approval
not pleasing people and getting their approval is that clear and how do we know this
is the case that if there is a conflict between the people's approval and Allah's approval
I pick Allah's approval I don't expect everyone to be pleased with me and so he
quotes
the people getting all the people on your side is an objective that is never attainable
it's
impossible
I do not believe there's any way to escape without upsetting someone there's no way around
this he's trying to say and so be keen on what benefits you whether it pleases
the people it might sometimes or displeases the people just focus on what is what is
possible and he cites that a man came to Al has the great Imam from uh
the Tiberian generation after the sahaba he met hundreds of the sahaba and the man said
to El Hassan
there's some I want to warn you I want to tell you something Sheikh there's people
that sit with you for no reason than to find things they can hold against you
they're mining for reasons to cancel you as we say nowadays that's why they sit with
you so he said back to the man that was cautioning him he said to him
take it easy on yourself meaning I don't take this stuff heavily I don't take it
to heart no big deal you also don't don't go overboard it's no big deal take
it easy on yourself he said because I set as one of my objectives in life
to reach paradise and I found that to be possible is it possible to reach Paradise
it is he said and I said as one of my goals in life to escape
the Hellfire and I found that to be possible and I sat as one of my
goals in life to get the people's approval and I found that it wasn't possible gen
as possible the fire is possible people's approval is not meaning all of them all the
time he said foreign
people don't even approve of God who created them and provides for them how are they
going to approve of a fellow creature like them right or wrong very wise way to
look at it and you gotta realize this book is about dealing with people part of
your manners with dealing with people will come from the fact that you are lowering your
expectations of people of them you know they say people are people they're not going to
stop being who they are and part of who they are is they're just different sometimes
these differences aren't even a bad thing right we just look at things differently understand things
differently sometimes people will insist on being evil also that's another reason why they'll never stop
laughing at you or never stop disapproving of you just get it out of your head
even God doesn't have Universal approval right and it was reported uh in
that
Musa
once
said
oh Allah they're saying things about me that aren't true they're slandering me they're accusing me
they're sort of suspecting me and so Allah inspired or revealed to Musa
I didn't Grant this to myself that people will never say bad things about me so
how can I grant it to you and Malik Allah he said since I understood people
since the day I finally figured it out I have never been pleased with their praise
nor displeased with their criticism they said why he said because the people that Praise You
are exaggerating and the people that disprace you are exaggerating meaning most of the time people
are just emotional they're not actually being accurate they're not actually being fair and so just
like I get it no big deal obviously it's normal to be pleased when someone Praises
you and to be displeased when someone insults you this is normal but what he means
is he's not thrown off his rocker what he means is this isn't a huge deal
for me it doesn't cause me to pause or make turns I gotta I have another
objective that's not it I'm going somewhere else so these things are not that influential
he said in another narration
there is nobody on earth except that he's got lovers and haters
and since that's the case let that let your lovers be those who obey God the
mighty some people some people will hate you why because you are pleasing to God and
they don't like that can you imagine some people are like this Eve you'll never be
able to appease them all he says in a little bit of an analysis here that
I'll summarize for you he says this is because pleasing the people is not possible nor
asked of you nor reported about anyone among you he says
it's
not
possible
theoretically it's not possible he says nor is it Mahmoud you are not commanded to seek
everyone's pleasure don't mean to harden yourself it's not your job nor has it ever been
reported about the righteous about the prophets about God himself never he says so since it
is impossible to avoid some of them being upset at you then they're going to be
upset at you while you're pleasing God or upset at you while you're displeasing God so
have half a brain he says and let them be upset at you if need be
while you're pleasing God and it will not harm you that you don't have the approval
of those that will not benefit you in this world or in the next what does
it give you and you know there's actually a Hadith about the fact that these aren't
uh separate subjects that if you seek the approval of everyone you will wind up displeasing
Allah and this will cause them to wind up not liking you anyway they're actually connected
and that is you know the Hadith is narrated and in the context of where it
was narrated or the backstory of why she mentioned it famously was because of the fitzma
you know there was a big standoff between in sort of the two major provinces of
the um and so at the onset especially she wanted to get Vengeance for from The
Killers of his cousin his tribesmen
disagreed and said listen I will not accept this I don't approve of this I can't
let you do this and so sent him a letter and she said to him the
messenger of Allah I heard him say I myself heard him say whoever seeks the pleasure
of the people while disobeying Allah Allah will relegate him to the people meaning Allah will
leave him for the people to help him and they'll never be able to help him
she's telling him be brave basically of course that concept is correct regardless of whether or
not it was correctly applied uh uh between Ali and especially from Allah aside but this
is something that the prophet salallahu alaihi wasallam said and the continuation of the Hadith he
said and whomever seeks the pleasure of Allah even if that angers the people Allah will
become pleased with him and cause the people to become pleased with him and by the
way the people that matter will become pleased with him so many times there are people
who get a lot of criticism even within their own families when they seek to please
Allah azzawajal their particularity about like you know what they eat or though what they don't
eat what kind of functions or events they attend and they don't attend eventually eventually these
people that are upset at you they wind up seeing that you are a better person
for it eventually they realize this is actually a good person yes he doesn't come to
the wedding where there's dancing but he also calls me and he also visits me and
he also checks up on me and more than everyone else so if you are consistently
trying to please Allah you will win people's hearts over Allah's Deen and his selfie will
cause people's hearts to to turn towards you just make sure you don't seek it directly
even at the expense of displeasing Allah because then you'll get neither they'll neither be pleased
with you nor will Allah be pleased with you and then you lost out on both
the next section
another sort of shade of humility he says he
was
they accept truth from wherever it comes and they give no consideration to who is saying
it that's called what in English what's that called being what being objective being impartial not
being biased right I'm not partial this way or partial I'm impartial I have no sides
I'm with the truth I'm seeking the truth the truth comes from whatever Direction I'm taking
it and you know this is what it means to be a Muslim because a Muslim
is a servant of God servant of Allah and Allah of his names is the ultimate
truth and so if you truly have servitude to Allah you will accept truth as part
of your service to God wherever you may find it you know there is a Hadith
it's a Hadith and sort of many scholars mentioned it's a weak Hadith some are attributed
to Allah but the wording is is important to remember which
is
two different narrations that hikmah wisdom precise truth wisdom right this is the Lost Property of
the believer when you have something that belongs to you and it's lost what do you
do you look for it what's yours right the why is it lost why some wisdom
some wisdoms in the Quran are not lost why some wisdom lost because Allah sprinkled it
among his creation he scattered it he distributed it on purpose to see if you're gonna
accept it even from places where it's difficult to accept it you get it that is
how he is testing whether you are true a servant of God or not whether I
like you or not whether you're agreeing with my sort of opinion or not I'm accepting
truth
the great companion he said in this regard whomever comes to you the truth make sure
you accept it from them even if there's someone distant from you and hate it to
you he said woman
and when someone comes to you with something wrong check them right reject it resist it
even if there someone beloved to you and closely related to you
Allah
after mentioning many many imams of the early Muslims he
says
because some of these imams were controversial more controversial than others he said the truthful person
the servant of God who is Zaki not the key the key means intelligent they're they
are intelligent but he says Zaki meaning the pure-hearted person person doesn't have the the pollution
of biases or Prejudice he's saying Assad the truthful is
he accepts from them all whatever truth he finds with them and he seeks with that
help in his mission in life which is worshiping Allah and does not reject any truth
or any benefit they may have because of Any shortcoming they have elsewhere and then dismisses
uh their value he says because completeness and Perfection belongs only to Allah lord of the
worlds and there is no servant except that he has his rank has his station meaning
beneath Allah meaning a station within the Stations of what imperfection some of us are more
perfect than others are more correct than others but we're all on this ladder somewhere
you know uh the great Imam uh
rather recent contemporary uh scholar on the Quran he
says
he says and it is known well known should not be disputed that we look at
any statement while turning a blind eye to the person stating it even if that person
may come off as the lowest of people to you we already saw he's talking about
the Quran we already saw in the Quran that Allah agreed with and concurred with the
statement of someone that committed the lowliest crime which is worshiping the son worshiping another creation
as if they're God in the story of Sabbath he said when Suleiman sent that message
uh to the Queen of Sheba right the queen of seba some say her name is
when he sent her that she pulled her advisory Council together and she said to them
I got a letter from Suleiman he's telling us to concede to his Reign to his
power and to stand down and to submit to Allah along with him uh but under
his rule right so she said in in Surah another account of this is the chapter
of the ants she said to her counsel Inn
that the Kings when they enter a town they ruin it
and they take its most honorable Elites and they humiliate them that's what she said so
what do you guys think we should do should we fight him because you guys know
what Kings do when they come to town Kings come to town they ruin it they
level it to the ground and they take their biggest sort of opponents or challengers the
biggest threats and they make an example out of them they make
at the end of the Ayah right after she says that Allah says
and that is what Kings do he's agreeing with this woman who is a pagan idolater
worshiper of the son at least according to the staff seat of what okay means and
so he's saying that should teach us all that no matter who's saying something true if
it's correct you gotta say yeah I gotta agree with you there it's correct uh of
course Allah is agreeing that that is the norm with Kings not that Suleiman would do
that just sort of important disclaimer before I get canceled but I don't need anyone's approval
that was a good exercise in the chapter before it right and uh you know Allah
the uh you have this I will summarize it he says on this point he says
and you know philosophers they've done so much wrong and so much damage to people's minds
and lifestyles in human history he's talking about non-muslim philosophers obviously right you think about all
these different Traditions out there people lost in their thoughts and then at the end of
the long journey to say the only thing I know is that I don't know and
right stuff like this uh he says but we have to keep in mind that these
philosophers not everything they say is worthless especially if we find some of what they say
is not rejected by our Sharia by our revelation
he
says
you think about the things they describe
like certain wisdoms life wisdoms and ways to sort of tame your uh your carnal desires
he says and the conspiracies that our inner sense our inner selves pull on us and
what happens when we don't have a conscience so they were basically very introspective and that
stuff is subject to personal analysis and sort of measuring the patterns of human behavior and
so they do have some there so be sure not to miss out on it you
know for example like what is he talking about who's familiar with the stoic tradition who
knows tradition is what's the stoic tradition anyone know mercium you got it you want to
give us like a yeah the stoic tradition is basically how to transcend Dunya but in
their terms right they basically say that passion is irrational that's their philosophy so if you're
able to like dim down your passions a little bit obviously worldly passions because he means
desires right if you can dim down your passions you'll do better in life you'll make
less Reckless decisions you'll be less emotionally broken because you're turning down your emotions you're not
getting too happy so you're not going to get too sad right and then they put
together sort of practices exercises on how to do this right there is a lot of
benefit in that right there is much our Dean came approving of this uh building on
this there's a lot of resemblance between these teachings of the stoic tradition that the philosophers
through trial and error have built on over the years and it being you know inspired
approved of even uh taught uh directly expressly in our in our tradition in the Quran
in the Sunnah and of course it is Flawless they are not here but he's saying
there's a lot of things there that are not disapproved of disqualified in our tradition make
sure you don't sell yourself short and miss out on it and then he gives so
many examples of Scholars that say this person is solid in Hadith then they tell him
but wait wait wait he's a murji is like a deviant ideology he says I don't
care he saw it in Hadith I'd love to hear Hadith from him you know would
take from a man that was from you guys know
what do they believe they basically believe that sins are a disbelief they don't have anything
called sins basically the sin and the disbelief kind of got you know flattened to one
thing so if you commit a sin you're not Muslim anymore very deviant that caused them
to excommunicate many Muslims including
under the presumption that they committed certain sins can you imagine like the slippery slope got
very ugly very fast very bloody very deviant people and others would accept with qualifier but
Hadith why
because he was very unlikely to lie because he believes that if he lies he's a
disbeliever so they were like extremists and So within certain parameters they have certain safeguards in
place uh to avoid certain unconscious biases but he will not consciously lie so if his
memory is known to be good I know he has Integrity because he's paranoid about Sin
therefore I'll accept his Hadith great objectivity great impartiality there
and he shares here uh a wisdom from a pre-islamic uh let me get his name
right I looked it up in English for you or Mahir this is like he died
in 580. uh the prophet saws was born approximately 572 just to give you a picture
he was known as like a wise man and a sage that was from the Karen
family in sassanid Persia close to the elites and the royalty of the assassinated Persian Empire
so in any case he reports from him that our Scholars collected this they appreciated this
they sort of use this as an example of you know the mentality of the Muslim
the humility in practice that the Muslim should try to embody that uh buzzur Jim har
or uh whatever his name was I can't say his name and take care of my
daughter that one's like uh an impossible one come on ladies anyone know it is it
a well-known name I've read it a gazillion times and I went to Wikipedia to make
sure like I'm pronouncing it right uh in any case it is recorded in our books
as Muslims that is the whole point that we have no problem sort of benefiting from
this Legacy when it is filtered through the values of the Quran and Sunnah that he
once said this great wise man and Sage that I have taken every point of benefit
I can find in this world from everything till I was able to even benefit from
the dog and the Raven and the Pig and the cats that's a good one right
he said as for the dog they asked him what can you possibly take from dogs
like like human beings were Superior he
said
it's man's best friend right it's loyalty to its family dog won't steal from your food
are they sort of giving you guys a free show ER
they know we're streaming so they they're thirsting for uh for attention
his loyalty to his owner was and his protectiveness his defensiveness regarding his women and come
near my woman right these are good qualities to have he says I noticed these in
the dog and I took him he said they said to him what about the Raven
he said that he has intense vigilance you know they say the Ravens always like one
foot one eye on Earth one eye in the sky right like they're checking am I
gonna get attacked from above or below they're always alert always Vigilant they're not walking through
life uh oblivious they said to him what you get from the pig what did he
get from the pig who's thinking with me
think about it has to be something good because the Muslim Scholars are approving of this
and it's not like you know the BLT what is it
huh
he
said
that he starts his day early to reach his goals as soon as he wakes up
what am I eating right so at least he's he has the tunnel vision and he
initiates his day early he's focused focus in the most lowliest voice but he's taking from
him what can be taken which is focus being goal oriented and focused ambitious if you
will they said to him would you how can you possibly take from a cat he
said
the fact that it asks gently without yelling you guys know what a cat doesn't want
something it comes and rubs up against your leg and stuff and you know it asks
with gentleness and it doesn't scream so he said I learned this from the cats
I'll finish off this section here we can actually do one more very quickly inshallah that
he narrates from Ibrahim who said that I asked
what is the definition of humility he said and who
um
for you to lower yourself to humble yourself to the truth and to comply with it
not just say okay to actually comply with it you know is like driving right to
be driven by it to be led by it to comply with it from whoever you
hear it even if it were the most ignorant of people you're still obligated to commit
yourself to it to accept it and commit yourself to it and the last narration from
hodeifa here he said
that
said
you might find out that you stumble on wisdom in the middle of a garbage dump
on top of a garbage dump if you do make sure you take it that's Allah's
test for us right that he scattered wisdom everywhere you got to be ready to Pivot
with the truth wherever it goes may Allah make us of those people
so this next section here is somewhat uh the same and somewhat different which is
which means they I use the word concede a lot but this really means concede meaning
to return to retract your position or your statement after you've said it because you can
like not know something and then learn and then but after you've already made a decision
or verbalized an opinion the stakes are higher still you're gonna you're willing to backtrack basically
and of the examples of this he gives is the famous story of um
during his caliphate of course the prosperity of the ummah was uh in full force and
it continued the momentum continued through Earthman and others and so people began raising the price
of which is the bridal Dowry the gift that is given to the woman social comparison
and sort of materialistic you know uh ills are seeping into the ummah people are now
raising the Mahar my daughter got this your daughter my daughter is going to get more
and your daughter got that and so people were complicating marriage as happens today right and
so Omar thought it would be justified for the greater good to set a maximum ceiling
on the Mahar
in
fact
so he said I'm gonna set them up at a maximum ceiling uh
and so a woman stood up in the middle of him declaring this new rule that
you can't ask for more than blank because you'd be burdening people therefore if you burden
them they're not going to get married and if people can get married easily enough then
the complication of the Haram or the complication of the Halal will be facilitating the Haram
they're going to go to the easier alternative if the fear of Allah is absent of
course so a woman got up and she said you have no right to do that
or Umar because Allah himself in the Quran said in Surat is
if one of you gives to their bride or bride to be a cantar you are
not allowed to take back any of it it's not a show you give this maharan
then after he said by the way I changed my mind I want my money back
but the issue is the Ayah doesn't say money the ISS pintar and the kintar is
like a a big chunk of gold basically a whole lot of gold a fortune if
you will and so she mentioned that the Ayah used the example of a sizeable Mahar
so why are you downsizing the Mahar and so Omar stopped for a second and he
said
this is a woman who has challenged Omar and in fact effectively did so effectively challenged
him in one narration uh
he
said
before you is a woman who is correct and a man who is mistaken you know
what the scholars say about this were it not for the humility in practice that Umar
had it would not have been difficult for Umar to think of some sort of what
we call nowadays right like some legalistic justification to say no but technically I can because
there's another ruling there that I can use an analogy for and he would have figured
out a way to argue if Omar were not open to the fact that he could
be wrong and that he should take it that he could take it back after he
said it you know there's a not so funny story of a man who lost his
stuff and so the the students around him said make Dua that Allah you know bring
your I forgot what it was back to you and so he raised his hand and
said yeah Allah do not allow any student of knowledge to find it student of like
the Islamic Sciences they said what why would you say that he said because of a
student of knowledge finds it he's going to figure out a way to compute in his
head why it's Halal to keep it technically the scholars disagreed on the threshold for lost
and found and sort of there is the trivial negligible amount there is and it is
subject sometimes it is the social norms and so he'll figure out a way some wiggle
room to not give me my stuff back so that's why our teachers used to tell
us the most dangerous thing in the world is knowledge without faith right when you got
a whole lot of ammo and no self-restraint to make you humble may Allah protect us
all and I'll share with you one final incident regarding retractions and with it I'll close
mentions in his famous compendium of history from who
said
is one of the earliest companions senior companion of the Prophet saws this is an incident
that took place after the death of rasulullah he was serving in a battle campaign just
as a regular Soldier not in any position of leadership
and so the enemy laid Siege to them had them surrounded was trying to basically basically
play the long game get them to make the first move or at least die running
out of resources trying to get them to uh get exasperated just laid Siege to them
from every angle so the Emir the commander of the army put out instructions that nobody
move don't get provoked don't break sort of our solid unit don't move nobody March we
gotta play this safe this is life or death nobody move and so one man one
guy the The Firm instructions the the very strict rule that the commander gave he misunderstood
it he understood the opposite he understood if you got a chance to go go if
you find an opening go the Amir was saying no matter what even if you find
an opening don't go it's too risky so he heard he understood the opposite so the
Emir brought him forward and had him beaten he was punished for jeopardizing the lives of
the rest of the army and so the man went back to camp and he was
just you know overwhelmed with
humiliation
and
this great so happy passes by him he says what happened to you and he tells
them the whole story he goes I misheard the guy and he still threw me a
mean beating and I've never been so disgraced in my life and he said come with
me grabs his sword and takes this guy this poor Soldier and marches to the Amir
sent the Commander's tent and he says to him did you ask him if he heard
you correctly or not now he gets to beat you the way you beat him and
so this the soldier after seeing do this and seeing the commander willing to give in
to the equal retribution the reparation or the retaliation the soldiers said no no no no
no I'm good I'm fine I'm all right I I forgive him I don't want walked
out and like he he was very exhilarated not by his own ego or Pride but
by the justice that was dealt and he said very famously
is
I will die on the day that I die while Islam is mighty I will die
while Islam is still mighty meaning this Islam thing is not a conversation table Islam is
the truth and Islam is about Justice and Justice will always be served because this Islam
thing is not some name or table talk or this is real and everyone bows to
Islam and the principles of Islam don't bow or bend for anyone that was the idea
and you saw masha'allah even the commander himself was ready from a foot soldier which would
have been more humiliating for him than it was for the man who was uh struck
by the higher-ups for this was of the humility they showed in practice and we can
benefit a lot from in so many different ways you know as one of my teachers
uh or the writers that I I I read for uh at length in the past
he used to say and what kind of piety taqwa is left in the ummah if
you don't have enough god-fearing-ness in you to retract the Tweet to retract the post to
retract an image When someone tells you ah by the way that's actually false information or
that's inappropriate or like it's unbefitting if you can't pull back one of these things right
then what is left in there what bowing to the truth and conceding to the hap
as the Servants of Allah are we it's a good point to reflect on personally for
each and for each of our individual lives and Allah Knows Best
oh